and when to welcome to this video
playing I am Tetrarch something like
that so let's see what he does for
probably the maroc see the recording
working yes I had some issues there last
two games I played are not on the video
because the recording software really
screwed it up really bit strange to be
honest I did an update and xsplit it's
probably the kind of software you
shouldn't update him okay I've got a
mainline Roxie point and I'm testing the
ecig setup then regrouping with Bishop
d1 and so on ahead in a recent game and
it turned out to be quite quite good for
white I played with g5 and that really
didn't work out all that well
yeah so you can sell form
I have b5 in this position I don't know
if it really helps but I 94 94
well I can take and then play maybe yeah
maybe I can do that 94 I can maybe take
it looks a bit strange but I can
probably take in general I should be
yeah I thought I can take I mean I'm not
saying you shouldn't have played the
movie it's just that I think this is a
viable continuation
[Music]
okay so is there threat
I don't know but I want to flick this in
anyway so before I take on c4 so what
what is this the a pawn is a little bit
weak
so I'm covering this something that I
would like to do is to regroup to
regroup my Bishop to e6 but Bishop g5 I
did did not take into account and now is
sitting there hmm not good
it's absolutely not a way to get rid of
this bishop
if you can somehow maybe Quincy eight I
should have tried in CA to evade this is
for p7 in an endgame I might be okay hmm
[Music]
at least have not made it then
and yes this okay this isthis is of
course possible Ruby semanas firmly
rupture rook to d1
now I don't really seem see anything
here I can do see no constructive plan
the one and I probably just have to go
back and then now Queen evade
hmm again after Queen trade I might be
alive okay so is there a way to free
myself a little bit this one King age
seven okay so the Queen will not enter
on age six anytime soon and I have to
try for some counter play now see and a
partner maybe also 94 in some cases
came
mmm Cawood c7 if he gets to the back
ring
I'm also checkmated more or less
time warning
yeah yeah I'm not sure if this is so bad
no I come on the only way to lose it
still yes great here Joe chick defend
their work time this crap position and
the first time you have equality total
equality after this I will under the
rook and I have more time on the clock I
simply never reckoned with Bishop d6
which is completely this is the worst
possible move into position
yeah besides blundering a piece yeah
yeah he I will just win on time on
position because I have the easier play
now yeah simply donating points there
for nothing anyway okay yeah when I was
worse but he team didn't manage to to
end it somehow yeah this this whole
thing was certainly debatable before was
possible him I wasn't sure about the
whole thing but the way it turned out
and this is looked absolutely terrible
but somehow somehow I was still hanging
on
wouldn't be surprised if he had a win
would guess this is why I was so angry
they've absolutely first time in the
game when I was a fine I'm blundering
and rook in one move yeah yeah I'm also
just like hanging on trying to defend
okay Queen a7 was winning yeah I mean it
he didn't have much time
for the first time I'm okay and then I
blunder Luke in one moment that's
fantastic
I simply never thought about Bishop d6 I
mean I don't know I was just thinking I
go King e6 f6 and then go from there
yeah okay thanks for watching